ハイあのちょっとあんまりはっきりとこうじょんとそんな
柄でもないですし僕が普段通りのなんか自分らしいとか出すことが今一番自分がすべき
ことなのかなと思ってなんですけどもうちょっとこの動画だけどうしても出したいなと
思って出させていただいておりますよろしくお願い致します
でも当たり前のようなことは別に言おうとは思ってません打つに入るとか3つの3つを
避けるとかもうそういう情報ってもどこでも見れると思うんですよネットでも見る指定
日を言ってるしいろんな人が言ってますもうユーチューバーさんとか有名な方とか
インフルエンサーとかいろんな方が言ってるんで改めて僕がわざわざ言う必要はないか
なと思うんでそこらへんはもう普通に調べてください調べてくださいと言うとかみんな
しっ
てると思った上でのお話をさせていただきますそれでも外出する人がいるそれでも
とても完成者数が多い東京から地方の方に入っちゃったりする人がいるという現状かつ
も東京でもなんかよく聞くんですけど
不要な外出をしたりお花見したりわざわざ予定もないのに趣味やとか人が多い場所に
入っちゃってるあの馬鹿もいるって言うのを聞いたことがあるねなんか
お掃除して達ってもう我々がイングレーサーとはいろんな人が多分どんなにあの
言ってもこれをするなありをするのは家から出てはいけません不要不急ので実はダメ
です人が集まる場所に行っちゃダメですとか言っても多分
意味がないと思うんですよいや本当にどれだけみんなで頑張ろうとかダメですこうし
ないというかみんなでうちにいようって言ってもあの
どうしても自分ではどこかに関係ないとかそれをやらなかった結果このままこの世界は
どうなっちゃうのかっていうのわからない人たちだと思うんですよ
ほんと黒一部の方ですよ僕の一帯のは本当にこれぜひあの不要不急の外出を控えてお家
にいる皆さん本当に頑張ってると思います本当によく頑張っているとして本当は怖くて
外にモテたくない思考
ないうちにかかり多分はなくて仕事はしたくないんですけども必要とされている仕事を
されている皆さん本当に助かっております
みなさんのおかげで我々の生活が成り立っているところがありますにもかかわらず
やっぱね行ってエース依存ですよどうしても自分の心のどこかで関係ないと思って外出
ちゃう人が不要不急でもね得し頭おかしい
静岡県の静岡スミス
飲んでるんですけども感染者数がとも4月中に違いで30人程度なんですよ僕たちも
控えなきゃいけないんですけども
土曜日なちょっと用事があって車でこう移動している時に家の近くの公園みたらもう
親子連れの子供たちがめちゃくちゃ集まってるんですよ公園にそれもまあヒックもせず
もう無くこれ見てちょっと関係ないんだろうなって思ってる人が本当にどうしようも
ないか
多いなぁとすごい心のどこかで感じてしまってどれだけがんばっです3つの3つを控え
ましょうと彼を家にいようとか頑張ってもやっぱ心に届かない人にはもう何が何でも
届かないと思うんで今回はそういう人たちのためにどうしても見てほしい動画を撮らせ
ていただいておりますあまり多くは語りません
これだけ聞いてくだされば助かります
はいあと皆さんにお任せします何をすべきかは分かっていると思うんでそれを行動に
移せないだけですテレビで僕が話したいことは本当に一つだけですあの
ある映画を見てほしいですツイッターとかねとって結構部材になってるんですけども私
が満を持して取り上げさせていただきますちょい昨日見ました
いやもう結構話題にはなってるんですけども改めて皆さん見てほしいですコンティ
ジョンという
絵がでございます2011年度ちょっと武笠の映画なんですけどもまぁ2時間以内で
見れますざっくりれて目すると今のこのホロだウイルスが流行っている世界の情勢状態
とめっちゃ
ちゃん切っている映画でございます泉北一人じゃなくてほぼ2週間ぐらい家で止まって
いる形跡が見たんですけどもうちょっと聞いてみましょうか
県勢の日のホームページを見たわけなんですけど
福井ていただきもんねみてどうだった本当でしょ今この状況じゃなかったら光栄なでも
ですけど
なちゃ
この状況になってみると
-震える住む結構エグかったよね後半ことは失ってたもんですよ
妙法と普通
濃すぎるの考えるだけでしても
このくださいあのおしゃべりな見識がこれほど言葉を打つくってコンテンツをどういう
映画かと言いますと全く同じでクリスもこれなウイルスのように運営者が世界中に蔓延
するっていう映画なんですけどもマジで増強がそっくり過ぎるんですよなんかその
アジアの地域で発生した美術で世界中が広まってとんでもない数の人間が死ぬっていう
映画なんですけどあんまりを
多くは語らないで本当にただたがとりあえずなんとなく人で見ていただきたいいろいろ
不要不急の外出は控えると言われているけどなんとなく出ちゃう人とかどこか心の中で
自分はねう書とか思ってる方は是非とも観てほしいなっていうかね寝てるところがもう
何だろう感染の仕方って良いんですか映画でも全く今の状況と一緒でペア来本当にては
ちゃんと洗ってほしいという話
結構しててそこが今と似てるなと思ったして完成されてもそのすごい所蔵が出て
無くなっちゃう方もいるし症状が出なくて助かるか誰もいるって言うところも本当に
入ってるし
外出を控えろっていう
結局何だその映画をあんまで言うとよくないがぜひ見てくださいただ
振るえば本当に本当にこれ8年9年前に作った映画なのかっていうぐらい今のこの
コロナウイルスが流行ってる世界の状態でマジで似てて最終的にその上ですが流行っ
ちゃうとどうなるかっていう世界まで見れると思うんでこのままだとどうなっちゃうの
かっていうのを本当に冷蔵かせている映画だと思ってるんでぜひ観ていただきたいと
思いますあの僕は本当に触れましたら結局誰
彼に言われたれ何かした方がいいよと言われるより実際そらやんなかった結果どうなっ
ちゃうのかというのを見せるのが一番効くと思うので是非とも見てほしいですねまたに
感染者数にほぼ止まってないしてね映画見て結構1変わっちゃって何をすべきか本当に
情報出まくってるんで一式的な話をさせていただきます1回来ないが
みてください根底ジョン僕は amazon prime で見たんですけどたしか
youtube に
有料であったし結構観てねと思うんですけど何か1回テレビでやってほしいです金曜
ロードショーとかでもいいんで1回なんかみんなが見れる状態で見てほしいぐらいでし
た
ぜひお時間がある方は見てみてください僕からは以上です本当に
見てほしいですよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
こんなに真面目な人ないと思うんだよっ
よろしくですザッ